ja ich kann nicht verstehen wie man als
Verteidigungsministerin in diesen
Kriegszeiten auf die Idee kommen kann in
den südurlaub zu fahren während die
Ukraine uns ja anflehen dass wir Ihnen
schwere Waffen liefern war sie im Beach
House Sylt unterwegs wie ich gelesen
habe und das ist aus meiner Sicht sehr
sehr unsensibel und auch instinktlos es
ist nicht so dass ich jetzt denken würde
dass so eine Verteidigungsministerin
kein Urlaub verdient hätte oder dass sie
in der Kaserne die Munitionskisten
packen soll aber ich glaube gerade in
diesen Zeiten ist es absolut falsches
Signal zum einen unsere Bevölkerung es
kommt so ein bisschen rüber als ob das
alles gar nicht so schlimm sei obwohl
zwei Flugstunden entfernt immer noch
Krieg herrscht aber noch viel schlimmer
es ist ein ganz schlechtes Zeichen in
Richtung der Ukraine den wir damit
zeigen wir helfen euch eigentlich nicht
so wie wir es können und das ist für
mich unverständlich Instinkt los und hat
mich geärgert
für mich ist das ein Symptom für eine
viel tiefer angelegte malese in der
deutschen Politik die viel beschworene
Zeitenwende in der deutschen gibt es
nämlich gar nicht die ist nicht
angekommen mit den Köpfen weder beim
Kanzler noch bei seinem Kabinett ich
habe auch den Eindruck noch bei der CDU
also die machen alle machen ihre
Geschäfte
die SPD ist wieder zurückgefallen wenn
ich mir Sigmar Gabriel anschaut wieder
zurückgefallen den vor Ukraine denken
und verteidigt Dinge die nicht zu
verteidigen sind ich habe jetzt im Daily
Telegraph ein Kommentar gelesen der hat
mich wirklich gerissen da schreibt ein
englischer Kommentator man muss darüber
nachdenken Sanktionen gegen Deutschland
zu verhängen Sanktionen gegen
Deutschland nicht gegen Russland weil
eben Deutschland nicht in die Schuhe
komme in diesem Konflikt weil
Deutschland nicht bereit sei die Energie
Importe aus Russland zu beenden und weil
Deutschland den alten Stiefel
weitermache in der Analyse stimme ich im
Zug bei den einer bei den Sanktionen
allerdings muss ich sagen das ist
natürlich eine krasse Richter aber wenn
im Ausland schon so gedacht wird wird
sicherlich nur beim nicht nur beim Dalli
Telegraph so gedacht sondern es gibt
überall Probleme was das Ansehen
Deutschlands angeht und wenn die
Verteidigungsministerin Urlaub macht ich
weiß gar nicht wie man in Sylt in ein
Beach House gehen kann gibt es dann
Beach House komischer Name für Sylt
jedenfalls bin ich auch nicht jedenfalls
bevor wir zu den Sanktionen kommen und
da würde ich natürlich dich gerne Fragen
Viktor eigentlich ist es doch so wenn
bei einem die Hütte brennt ja da bleibt
man ja auch zu Hause und fährt nicht in
den Urlaub dementsprechend wie kann es
denn sein was ist das auch für ein
Symbol an die deutsche Bevölkerung das
Frau Lambrecht jetzt als
Verteidigungsministerin mein Urlaub
machen zu müssen es ist ein Symbol für
mangelnde Lernfähigkeit denn Frau
Lambrecht ist Teil der Ampelkoalition
und hat gerade Schmerz verliebt wie eine
Ministerin in ihrem eigenen Kabinett
zurücktreten musste wegen eines Urlaubs
in einer Krise und was macht sie einfach
später wie Herr steiniger Völk richtig
sagt sie fährt in Urlaub wie blöd kann
man eigentlich sein also ich habe
gedacht wo ist der Lerneffekt überhaupt
nicht da Wahnsinn und auch noch mit
Bärbel Bars der
spd-bundestagspräsidentin also dümmer
geht's nicht
Bela dümmer geht es nicht sagt Viktor du
jetzt Kommunikationsberater hättest du
ihr geraten ins speedshows nach Sylt zu
fahren nein natürlich nicht weil ich
meine so viele Politiker haben Ärger mit
ihren Urlauben gehabt jeder weiß doch
was da auf einen zukommt verstanden
sein Nachbarstaat NRW da waren drei
glaube ich Minister oder Ministerin in
nordrhein-west aus Nordrhein-Westfalen
auf Mallorca Urlaub während die Menschen
in der AR ertranken also auch da gab es
gab es natürlich entsprechende Vorgänge
die zu kritisieren sind und wir hätten
sie sich ja auch gedacht getan als
steiniger aber
insofern jeder weiß auch wenn als
Politiker in so einer Phase nach Sylt
fährt dass er sich Ärger einholt bei
Sylt als Urlaubsinsel der Reichen und
der schönen gilt es gibt auch andere
Ecken das wissen wir auch alles aber
sowas kommt immer raus das wissen wir
aus verschiedenen anderen Urlauben und
es gibt immer eine Skandalisierung auch
eine Verteidigungsminister manchmal
Urlaub verdient das ist richtig nur es
gibt einfach das falsche Signal es kann
wie hier an dieser Stelle natürlich
politisiert werden und das muss man
wissen denn wenn man seinem Gegner eine
solche Vorlage gibt dann verwandelt er
sie natürlich auch aber bei Uli das ja
hier ein bisschen auf die Metaebene
gezogen hat dann muss man ja auch eins
mal sagen ich meine die Armee was auch
immer der lieben Frau Ministerin
vorgeworfen wird die ist doch nicht im
Zustand weil sie seit drei Monaten da
Verteidigungsministerin ist sondern über
steiniger das müssen Sie schon mit ihrer
Partei dazu rechnen lassen denn sie
haben mit der CSU alle
Verteidigungsminister der letzten Jahre
seit 2005 also kann ja jeder Nachrichten
gestellt und die Armee ist in diesem
beklagenswerten Zustand weil erst der
jungen da war dann war er Guttenberg da
dann war er de maizier da dann war Frau
von der Leyen da und dann war Frau
Kramp-Karrenbauer da und die haben es
irgendwie alle nicht hingekriegt die
Armee in einen Zustand zu versetzen
einer hat noch die Wehrpflicht
abgeschafft dass sie jetzt verteid ist
und da muss man sagen das sollten wir
auch nicht ganz ausklammern vor dem
Hintergrund dessen dass wir hier
verschiedene andere Themen mit
diskutieren
ist glaube ich schon also ich nehme die
Kritik dateidigen sie nichts was nicht
zu verteidigen ist
würde mir fernliegen
was nicht so verteidigen ist ich
erinnere mich noch gut an den
cdu-bundesparteitags war mein erster als
uns zu Gutenberg erklärte warum wir
jetzt die Wehrpflicht abschaffen müssen
und alle standen und alle standen auf
den Tischen und haben im zugejubelt
natürlich überlegen in was für einer
Zeit war das gleichzeitig will ich
natürlich schon eins sagen am Schluss
geht es natürlich auch nur mit Geld und
wenn ich mir anschaue wie wird die
Diskussion über zwei Prozent Ziel in den
letzten Jahren geführt hatten dann war
die Union die einzige Partei die das 2%
Ziel immer wieder auch gefordert hat und
wir natürlich in der Problematik waren
dass es insbesondere bei der SPD aber
früher die Koalition und dann kein
großer Zustimmung das sind die Panzer
der Bundeswehr als Sparbüchsen benutzt
worden ja das haben sie ja immer mehr
stillgelegt worden da sind ja höchstens
noch die Hälfte der heutigen Panzer vor
allen Dingen nutzbar naja schwarz waren
und insofern
also man muss das schon selbst sie sind
ja auch bereit dazu wie man merkt das
muss man selbstkritisch betrachten heute
nachdem der Krieg in der Ukraine ist
sieht man vieles anders ich auch man
sieht vieles anders aber man muss bereit
sein darüber zu reden wir sind gerade
was sehr spannendes gesagt Herr
steiniger sie haben gesagt man es
braucht Geld das haben sie ja gerade
gesagt wir haben ja jetzt das Geld wurde
jetzt bereitgestellt was ich mich aber
manchmal Frage braucht es Geld oder
braucht es auch besseres Management ich
habe mir mal angeschaut wie schlecht
eigentlich unser Etat ist und wenn man
es zum Beispiel nehmen wir jetzt mal
Russland vergleicht haben wir jetzt gar
nicht so viel weniger Ausgaben für
Militär als beispielsweise andere Länder
dementsprechend muss man nicht auch
sagen es wurde jetzt einfach mal so als
Bürgern habe ich mich jetzt wirklich
gefragt so wir geben jetzt mal hier 100
Milliarden los aber muss man nicht erst
mal überlegen okay wo Sika dein Geld
durch was muss man besser machen einen
Plan aufstellen fehlt nicht vielleicht
eher der Unternehmergeist in der
Bundeswehr als das Geld ich glaube man
muss beides machen man muss auf der
einen Seite das Geld zur Verfügung
stellen aber dann muss man halt auch
dazu kommen dass man das Geld effektiv
dann auch ausgibt und sie wir haben das
Beschaffungsamt in Koblenz da sind sage
ich mal die Wege durchaus bürokratisch
die machen aber ehrlich gesagt auch nur
das was wir Ihnen als Politik
vorgeschrieben haben sprich im im Panzer
muss auch die neun Monate schwangere
Frau die als Soldatin unterwegs ist
eigentlich irre so etwas und wenn diese
Krise ein gutes hat dann ist es
hoffentlich dass wir da mal mit dem
stahlwesen durchgeht Nena fragt ja nach
einem gemeinsamen Spirit um zu überlegen
was man dem Geld anfängt das gibt es ja
nicht bisher dieses gemeinsame Runde der
der Bundestagsparteien wo sie sich
zusammensetzen und gemeinsam besprechen
ist nicht nur eine regierungsaufgabe da
das ja ans Grundgesetz gehen soll und
auch das Grundgesetz verändert werden
muss mit einer Zweidrittelmehrheit
müssen die mindestens die Union noch
dran beteiligt werden und das kann man
schon erwarten aber das ist ja nichts
passiert also es gibt ein Beschluss für
die Beschaffung eines neuen
Jagdflugzeugs und das war es erstmal
wenn es trotzdem so stimmt tatsächlich
ehrlich gesagt nicht weil also intern
verhandeln wir als größte
Opposition so natürlich derzeit mit der
Ampel ich höre aus den Gesprächen dass
das ja etwas ruckelt weil nämlich die
Andeutung die 100 Milliarden gar nicht
nur für die Bundeswehr ausgeben will
sondern da vielleicht auch noch ein paar
andere Ideen hat wo es Geld unterkommen
soll und uns ist eben wichtig die 100
Milliarden Euro sollen komplett für die
Streitkräfte ausgegeben werden wir
brauchen bessere Beschaffung das was sie
gerade eben genannt haben und von daher
sind wir immer die Ampel hat den
Bildungsetat um 17% gekürzt was sagen
sie dazu
tja es wäre jetzt nicht meine Priorität
ich kann sagen seit ich im Deutschen
Bundestag
andersrum ist meine Priorität wäre nicht
gewesen hier zu einer Kürzung ich bin
seit 2013 Mitglied des Deutschen
Bundestags in der Zeit haben wir diesen
Etat verdoppelt gehabt von daher würde
ich mir wünschen dass wir da ein Stück
weit mehr kontinuiert Kontinuität hätten
aber wenn sie in so einem riesengroßen
Haushalt mit mehreren hundert Milliarden
Euro durchgehen da finden sie schon in
paar Ecken auch Geld das mal einsparen
können aber ich stelle dir deswegen mich
interessieren sie sind ja Finanzfachmann
sie sind im Finanzausschuss sind ja auch
Experte wir haben ja erlebt und das
meine ich jetzt ohne parteipolitische
Kritik wirklich das aber es verschiedene
Versuche gegeben hat bei der Bundeswehr
diesen Milliarden Flüssen irgendwie auf
die Spur zu kommen Ursula von der Leyen
hat das wirklich intensivst versucht
indem sie halt mit Kind sie reingebracht
hat am Ende ist das auch schief gelaufen
aber sie hat zumindest versucht und
trotzdem hat man das Gefühl die gibt es
Milliarden die reingesteckt werden in
die Bundeswehr die aber trotzdem
ineffizient gebraucht werden
Softwaren braucht es nicht eine stärkere
auch Aufsicht finanziell Finanzaufsicht
über die entsprechenden Ausschüsse und
man sagt wir kontrollieren wirklich mal
genau wie die Durchflüsse und Abflüsse
sind tatsächlich sage ich jetzt mal als
Bundestagsabgeordneter genaues Gegenteil
also ich beschneide jetzt eigentlich
meine eigene Kompetenz es ist also so
Investition in der Bundeswehr ab 25
Millionen Euro müssen durch den
Haushaltsausschuss so das führt dazu
dass jede größere Investition 25
Millionen im Rüstungsbereich ist ja dann
auch schneller
muss sozusagen immer jeweils für den
Ausschuss aufbereitet werden kommt dann
erst in der Sitzung wird dann da
entsprechend formell auch
durchdiskutiert das heißt uns wird auch
sage ich mal aus dem Apparat selbst
zurückgespiegelt das natürlich diese
Dinge auch dafür sorgen dass am Schluss
sage ich mal eben nicht so schnell
aufgrund des Haushaltsrechts agiert
werden kann
mein Thema ist wir sind in so einer
existenziellen Krise und ich glaube
viele haben es auch gar nicht kapiert in
was für einer existenziellen Krise wir
sind dass wir einfach ganz viel neu
denken müssen und dazu gehört aus meiner
Sicht auch sowas wie Vergaberecht wie
Beschaffung wie Bürokratie und Persisch
schneller schneller werden abschaffen
und noch mal das Beispiel es ist so dass
bei der Vergabe dieses einen Panzers
auch die schwangere Frau im neunten
Monat hätte drin ist glaube ich
insgesamt an der verständigen Aufsicht
von Leuten die was von der Sache
verstehen also wir haben ja mitgekriegt
was für enorme Beträge durch
Beratungsunternehmen im
Verteidigungsministerium insbesondere
bei von der Laun line abgezockt worden
sind Hunderte von Millionen jedes Jahr
mit null-ergebnis muss man sagen er muss
von draußen betrachtet aber in unter
solchen Bedingungen greifen natürlich
die Rüstungskonzerne auch
schamlos zu die nehmen Preise die sie
kriegen und wenn niemand da ist der sagt
ein Panzer den ihr für 500 Millionen
verkaufen wollt den könnte auch für 250
Millionen verkaufen wenn das gezahlt
wird machen dies auch und deshalb
versickern da so ungeheure Beträge ohne
dass man einen Effekt merkt